5 42 on friday morning what's cool it's
cool how about when you're looking for a
friendly big game challenge why go to
the leaders of the cities and states
where the teams are from when you can go
straight to
the principal's office yeah the rams are
playing the bengals sunday but
did you know those same two teams are
challenging each other right here in las
vegas from the clark county school
district it's the rams of rancho taking
on the bengals of bonanza to see what
each will do if the other team wins we
start with principal darlene delgado and
her team from rancho high school the
rams are going to win so we're really
full-blown ready to go we're going to
win
so you're looking forward to bonanza
people wearing rancho jerseys absolutely
we even have the jerseys ready for them
to wear
sorrancho is one of the oldest high
schools here in clark county and we
opened in 1954.
oh my gosh so the bengals are the young
kids they opened in 1976. they better
respect their elders this team does not
look good in tiger stripes so get ready
for the green
george anis and his team from bonanza
high school they came roaring right out
of the game you guys are fired up for
the super bowl yeah we can't wait we're
gonna crush the ram just in case if by
some chance the rams should happen to
win would you agree to put on a rancho
jersey for a day oh my goodness so i
don't know stop
no
oh okay because i don't have to worry
about it because the bengals are going
to win anyway so
oh my i think we have a double throw
down i guess we'll find out on monday
which principal will be wearing the
other schools jersey so much fun hanging
out with the admin teams from both
schools now if you know something cool
at school please let us know cool at
school under the community tab at
eightnewsnow.com or just send us an
email coolascool eightnewsnow.com john
heather love that and well good shout
out to the the bengals for bringing out
the red carpet for they did fantastic
everything about that was perfect